attention aux excès de vitesse sur ce
tronçon de maurepas une étude réalisée
en février indique que sur une semaine
plus de 800 véhicules dépasse la vitesse
autorisée
c'est la raison de ce dispositif de
prévention une première pour la commune
nous avons des axes comme celui qui est
derrière moi venue de gastines où il ya
quatre mille véhicules par jour et dont
35% de ses véhicules dépassent largement
les 50 km heure
l'idée c'est de sensibiliser le public
et d'avoir des actions aussi de
répression autour des équipements
publics et des écoles notamment à la
période des sorties scolaires
l'attestation
cet automobiliste appréhender place de
bretagne ne roulait pas trop vite
elle a oublié de boucler sa ceinture et
son sort avec un simple rappel à l'ordre
plus de peur que de mal non et voilà ça
c'est sûr que la ceinture elle est
obligatoire et les bandes de l'avoir
ceinture téléphone au volant et excès de
vitesse
l'opération de prévention réalisés par
les neuf agents de la police municipale
avec de nouveaux équipements comme un
radar laser vise surtout à sensibiliser
les conducteurs pour aujourd'hui oui on
va rappeler quelques consignes par
rapport aux distances de freinage au
vitesse réglementée que ce soit sur en
agglomération hors agglomération et
aussi par rapport à l'alcoolémie et les
dangers de la route que cela représente
ces opérations se poursuivront dès la
rentrée sur d'autres axes de la commune
concernée par ces vitesses excessives